i want to go back because frank you have
a
you know what a very rare achievement
which is that all of this conversation
is happening in the shadow of your work
and your thinking and the end of history
is an often misquoted misremembered book
can you refresh us on what you were
actually arguing them yet because it's
the end of history with a capital h
right which is very important but what
was the central thesis of that book
yes well let's see if i can think of
that argument
i
i
usually get asked it once or twice a day
for the last 30 years so that is the
price yes i'm afraid yeah i have a lot
of practice well
uh first of all i would
i would explain what the end of history
those words mean so history
is history with a capital h today we
would call it something like
modernization or development
that is to say the slow evolution of
human
social organization over the millennia
as you go from hunter-gatherer societies
to tribal societies to i don't know
feudalism to you know an industrial
society and then wherever we are today
that's history and then the end is not a
stopping it is the direction that that
progress is uh pointing us towards
and um
there was a well
karl marx had a you know he bought into
the idea that there was history in this
progressive sense and he also talked
about an end of history for him
the end of history would be communism
because that was the highest form of
human
organization that resolved all of the
contradictions of prior
forms and my observation back in 1989
was we weren't going to get there
we weren't going to get to this higher
stage that we
could get to liberal democracy connected
to a market economy
but it wasn't clear that there was
another stage in social evolution
higher than that better than that and
that that's you know where we would uh
end up uh i did not predict that
everybody would end up being a peaceful
you know democracy but i said that there
is this larger
process you know call it modernization
that is valuable you know people don't
want to live in poor
chaotic less developed countries they
want to live in you know switzerland or
canada or you know britain
that has a high level of wealth where
you can
you can educate your children you don't
have to worry about your physical
security the way you do in many uh poor
societies and you know that's really
what the meaning of the end of history
was which then leads me onto the
question of why didn't that happen to
russia after the end of a cold war why
didn't it become a liberal democracy
well i do think that there are uh you
know cultural traditions that can get in
the way i mean so
many factors
one of them was
just bad policy and i really do think
that
a lot of the especially the american
economic advisors that were
talking to
russian policymakers after the soviet
union fell apart gave them bad advice
they made a much too rapid transition to
a market economy they didn't have the
and it was based on a really fundamental
misunderstanding they didn't understand
you need a state in order to have a
market economy a functioning state and
the you know the soviet union had just
dismantled its state and so
that was part of it i think that
you know just the
shock of losing an empire that rapidly
was deeply traumatizing to a lot of
people
it shouldn't been because i i believe
there's a country in this neighborhood
that lost an empire at some point in the
not too distant past and it didn't go
into this big revenge you know effort to
reconquer lost territories but i do
think that there is a tradition in
russian national identity that
understood its own identity in terms of
the domination of its region and that
simply just didn't go away
and then you know i think uh part of it
is just the luck of particular leaders
and i think we've got a lunatic running
this country right now
who is just fixated on that what he
regards as a historical uh injustice but
you could have imagined other outcomes
you know boris yeltsin could have
appointed somebody other than you know a
kgb agent to
be the next president of russia and we
may have been on a very different path
there's a great error actually
an extremely dangerous error being
unfolding at the moment which is to say
that um putin is mad
now he may be solid he may be isolated
he shows many of the characteristics of
isolation
there may be people not telling him the
bad news that might be why he'll sleep
scapegoats for the failure he'll feel
sack a lot of his people he already has
military and
and intelligence but when one says that
one is making the the classic error of
liberals
which is to say that underneath all
human beings are rational in the sense
that liberals understand rationality
what they really want is freedom peace
prosperity always i think wolfovitz said
about iraq he said two years from now
they'll all be sitting reading the wall
street journal and checking their stock
prices
didn't happen
um and not only because of american um
um
mistakes
uh this can lead to
catastrophe because it leaves out the
possibility
of that uh um a ruler like putin with
goals
uh goals about
reviving uh russia in its
bizarrest or perhaps its soviet form
uh unifying it uh having it as not being
as a kind of a world historical uh force
in the world
um um
in in human affairs there is goals and
we leave out the possibility which has
been many times exhibited in history
that people will put as human beings
leaders and even some of their followers
will put away put on one side these
liberal goals
but apply
um
some other goals
instead i think he is rational he's been
preparing this for a long time
um he's um turned the economy into a
fortress it's in people say it's in free
fall now well they can probably still
feed themselves because 80 of their food
is domestically produced it'll be other
parts of the world the developing world
that face shortages and
and hunger
you